welcome to this video step by step again
yeah I recently got to win against him
I'm very very lucky when I don't really
fare well against him I don't know why
okay we had a queen's gambit accepted in
the earlier game but this time got a
classical Queens gambit key with bishop
at for a six Joe okay I don't really
know
yeah just play the order normal-looking
moves maintaining this bind down on the
queenside let them it's a little bit of
a it's similar to some other lines Sam
in this in this variation but in this
particular case black has this knight c6
option so Queen a4 I guess b5 looks
wrong night before is a problem and so
do this
okay so wow he's allowing be five and
six that's quite remarkable i also have
Bishop b5 which is not bad what is he
doing after we should be fine a Queenie
ada ok so I'm going for be five then be
five and c6 okay so is he is just giving
giving up the piece it's not not a bad a
practical decision may be okay it takes
bc i always have those intermediate
moves them okay let's do this Queen a 70
s got Queenie aid okay I always have
this move for a temple gain just wonder
if there's something better okay did
that make sense taking it Shh 7-under
and the view Queen s7 he will play Queen
a that's not not that that easy
technical technically just get stuff
developed Yemen so I'm get knight c6 cm
oh wait that we takes us it's actually
good Bishop f 695 is pretty good just a
bit slow
Bishop c5 Bishop f6 those source moves
can be can be a bit irritating here too
goodnight e2 and therefore i'm still a
bit cautious here i tend to screw up
against the sky I don't know why and how
would somehow and I have problems and
even with the p's up I'm kind of kind of
cautious maybe here get the straight at
him and Quincy 8 as a medium so we
cannot play Queen d2 or something
check okay so i got queens off okay my
pawn structure isn't very good that's
not it's not that easy to win g6 is
helpful of course because he just
weakens the dark squares quite a bit ok
this one good 94 now threatened
one night f4 I know I'm just I'm let's
win the peace let's win the peace that's
it last year resign ok gotta win in here
yeah he later pleaded to be too weird
here ya hear I don't really know if this
was so great a knight c6 after this it
looks looks difficult I'm threatening b5
and c6 at his total bind that kills the
the bishop on on on c 8 th em now sure
okay well this is not really working but
this this is normal but then what is
this I'm just basically having to tune
to pieces off side that can play on the
Queen on the on the kingside like here
and trying to do something they're like
G 495 trying to say that those two
pieces don't defend yeah he went for
this sacrifice to muddy muddy the waters
a little bit I think I kept reasonable
control him might be five yeah the
computers more active in this position
but I was I just wanted to keep things
coordinated yeah here he cannot do
something like that because I Quincy aid
Jeff so trades I was surprised at you
when g6 because that makes trading pawns
more difficult time but it's probably a
win in any case probably his bishop on a
aid is just too bad here he stumbled a
chance but I don't think it was it was
some possible to put up a serious
resistance that the bishop is too bad
okay well thanks for watching